[Música]
e
a
escala en parís braulio modo
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con la televisión france24
en español en la que cada semana damos
la palabra a artistas gente de la
ciencia de las artes del mundo de la
política y de la sociedad civil los
franceses decidieron dar al presidente
manuel macro un segundo mandato de cinco
años en la segunda vuelta electoral
celebrada el pasado domingo 24
enmanuel macrón obtuvo 58 2% de los
votos en tanto que es la candidata de la
ultraderecha marine lepén alcanzó
41,8 por ciento de dicha votación el
nivel más alto nunca antes logrado por
una candidata de esa corriente política
cuáles son las principales lecciones que
se pueden sacar de dicha votación qué
desafíos y qué riesgos incurre tanto el
presidente como las fuerzas políticas
que han participado en ella para hablar
de ello saludamos en la presencia en
nuestro estudio de algo rubén echeverría
investigador de la universidad de
lausana profesor de asistente de
sociología política aldo bienvenido a
esta escala en parís gracias por estar
con nosotros
digamos que una cuestión que sale a
relucir de esta segunda vuelta electoral
es una la política una fractura que
reflejan las distintas tendencias que
han emergido con los votos y que al
mismo tiempo de una u otra manera
también reflejan la fractura territorial
que se está viviendo en el país cuáles
son las medidas que rápidamente debería
implementar el presidente manuel macro
en su segundo mandato para evitar que
esas fracturas no se vuelvan un abismo
político claro
las fracturas efectivamente
territoriales políticas que se reflejan
en estas elecciones yo creo que las
ilustran bastante bien lo que ha
sucedido con el movimiento de los
chalecos amarillos que podría haber
hecho y manuel macro no cualquier
presidente francés en ese momento pues
darse cuenta que hay una crisis de
representación es decir una crisis
política de que hay gente que no se
siente básicamente representada por el
sistema político por cómo está
estructurado y entonces lo que podría
haber hecho es para eso dotar a la
ciudadanía de mayores dispositivos de
participación ciudadana como por ejemplo
se reclamaba en ese momento el
referéndum de iniciativa ciudadana es
decir mayores dispositivos de
participación política y al mismo tiempo
la fractura territorial se ve de forma
muy clara también en el voto de que hay
en francia que es un territorio bastante
ruralizado bastantes territorios que no
tienen acceso a servicios de proximidad
que no tienen acceso a los mismos
servicios públicos que en otros lugares
entonces atender a esa medida a esa
demanda mediante mayor fiscalización
mayor fiscalidad que esté bien
distribuida en el territorio habría sido
una de las claves junto a los mecanismos
de participación política porque según
todos es uno de los primeros desafíos
del tercio enfrentado inmediatamente en
efecto en efectos ahora ahora el espacio
político como ha quedado pues roto ha
quedado completamente dividido lo
muestra muy bien el ascenso tanto del de
la antigua frente nacional de marine le
pen como también de la francia en su
misa subir también en cierta manera de
la abstención son formas de demostrar
este hastío hacia al menos el presidente
manuel macro ni su forma que ha tenido
de dirigir el país en los últimos cinco
años cuando ya al mismo tiempo el
presidente manuel macro es el primer
mandatario después del año 2000 cuando
se modificaron las leyes en este país
que se redujo
el periodo de presidencia de 7 a 5 años
en obtener una segunda reelección esto
es muy importante al mismo tiempo lo
hace con un 37 por ciento de los votos
del electorado del país quiere decir que
su segundo mandato va a hacer una
presidencia débil bueno en efecto ese es
uno de los pocos mandatarios que ha
revalidado su presidencia pero también
es verdad que es el segundo o sea su
segunda presidencia como también de
hecho la primera lo consigue ante la
extrema derecha es decir donde sabemos
que se activa un cordón sanitario que
todavía sigue funcionando aunque en esta
ocasión se ve debilitado no es verdad
que podríamos pensar porque es verdad
que el presidente macro no logra sólo
entre el 37 y el 38 por ciento de los
electores inscritos y con un aumento de
la abstención que lleva en efecto que
llega prácticamente el 30 por ciento y
se convierte en uno de los récords de la
de la quinta república es verdad que
esta crisis de representación no sólo no
sólo se ve en el caso francés se ve más
allá en europa pero en el caso de macrón
que se encuentra con estos desafíos que
mencionábamos antes antes y con cinco
años más hacia adelante donde va a tener
que hacer frente también a su arrogancia
a la figura que se ha forjado pues es
verdad que igual se encuentra en una en
una crisis o por lo menos en una
legitimidad más fisurada entonces esto
se verá también en las distintas
contestaciones sociales que puedan salir
frente a sus medidas más polémicas como
por ejemplo la reforma de las pensiones
y prolongación de la edad de jubilación
ahora bien hablamos de un poco de la
candidata marín depende decíamos en un
principio la ultraderecha ha obtenido un
récord como nunca antes de las
elecciones presidenciales esto
representa un maravilloso salto de ocho
puntos con respecto a la elección del
2017 es sólo un voto dijéramos que ha
recuperado los votos de la otra extrema
derecha notablemente dricks o hay otra
cosa más que ha apoyado la segunda
vuelta la votación de obtenido marín
depende bueno en efecto el hecho de
tener otro caladero de votos de la
ultraderecha en este caso con la
candidatura de eriksen pues ha servido a
que también efectivamente prolongue pues
su apoyo en la segunda vuelta
pero la candidatura es hemos como toda
una estrategia que también se inicia por
parte de marín lepén cuando toma las
riendas del antiguo frente nacional y de
la actual agrupación nacional es la
normalización el hecho de intentar
aparecer como una candidata mucho más
presidenciable una candil que de hecho
esto es lo que muestran las encuestas
que aparece como una candidata más
presidenciable como una candidata que se
teme menos a pensar balizada exacto
normalizada desde abolida como dicen
aquí en francia pero a pesar de ello sí
que sigue habiendo todavía un cierto
temor a la candidatura de
marín de penn se le sigue viendo como
una candidata racista como una candidata
xenófoba por un gran parte de la
población por lo tanto no lo ha logrado
del todo pero mejora en ese aspecto se
le ve también como más competente en
relación sobre todo 2017 donde le vimos
particularmente en el debate bastante
desorientada y entonces pues ha mejorado
mucho en eso y efectivamente en una
segunda vuelta
efectivamente ahí existe un cordón lo
interesante es que existe un cordón
sanitario contra contra contra marin de
penn por supuesto contra la extrema
derecha que se ve desde 2002 pero lo
particularmente interesante de estas
elecciones de esta segunda vuelta es que
también existe un cordón sanitario que
se activa contra emmanuel macrón es
decir para que el 12 por ciento de los
electores que han votado a marín lepe lo
hacen también con un bloque
exclusivamente contra contra macrón y
sólo el 16 por ciento lo hace como
bloque contra contra marin de penn por
lo tanto porcentajes bastante similares
el odio hacia asia emanuel macrón puede
también efectivamente traducirse en un
voto también más alto hacia marín que es
algo inédito para la historia de la
quinta república y en este sentido hay
muchos son muchos los frentes que te da
que tendrá que enfrentar el presidente
manuel macro dónde están notablemente el
incrementar el poder de compra este el
tema ecológico es el tema de la reforma
política de la reforma fiscal está la
cuestión de la guerra en ucrania
finalmente un segundo mandato que se
puede ir va a comenzar en un terreno
minado si totalmente sobre todo vamos a
ver cómo como sigue haciendo frente a
esta crisis
de la inflación como responde también
internacionalmente a la alusión de la
guerra de ucrania donde se posicionó de
forma hábil en las negociaciones con el
presidente de lenski y también con el
presidente vladimir putin pero es verdad
que no ha dado frutos y eso es lo que
puede también eso es lo que también
puede explicar que ese efecto bandera
que él funcionó también en los sondeos
al principio luego se vio se vio
reducido en los apoyos electorales
entonces efectivamente vamos a ver qué
medidas para el poder adquisitivo y para
y para también efectivamente la crisis
ecológica donde por el momento ha habido
muchas bellas palabras durante el primer
quinquenio de manuel macrón pero poca
poca aplicación de políticas realmente
ambiciosas valientes e interesantes es
verdad que ahora ha hecho un pequeño
guiño a la izquierda hablando utilizando
el lenguaje de sonic - o hablando de
planificación ecológica diciendo que va
a nombrar a ministros directamente
ecologistas vamos a ver qué es lo que
sucede porque en los cinco años que ha
dejado macrón no nos dejan pensar que
sea muy valiente en este sentido aldo de
manera breve porque el tiempo se va muy
rápido acaban de salir estadísticas
publicadas por europea por bruselas
donde se muestra que el gasto público en
seguridad social en francia representa
59 2% del producto interno bruto francés
8 puntos más por encima de la media de
toda la unión europea y aún así el
presidente macro nos ha podido sacar la
etiqueta de ser un presidente de los
ricos de manera breve esto tiene
implicaciones para su segundo mandato sí
por supuesto porque es verdad sí sí
francia todavía tiene un gasto social
considerable lo que hay que entenderlos
en términos relativos es decir macrón es
el que realmente se ha atrevido incluso
más que nicolas sarkozy a tocar y tocar
básicamente el sistema el sistema social
francés lo vimos durante la primera
parte de su quinquenio donde por ejemplo
si tomamos el caso de la salud recorta
más de 15 mil millones en el sector
llevando al personal hospitalario a
situaciones límite y efectivamente
también exonerando recortando en
impuestos hacia hacia los más ricos con
el impuesto de solidaridad a la fortuna
perdiendo mil millones efectivamente
también la flat tax también tenemos el
impuesto de competitividad y empleo es
decir en efecto y luego también el
recorte puede parecer poco pero para las
familias más modestas pues hacía notar
que era el recorte de las app el de las
ayudas a la vivienda entonces además de
eso también ha sido un presidente que
como decíamos ha mostrado de forma muy
arrogante mostrando un desprecio de
clase muy considerable hacia los parados
hacia los huelguistas hacia las personas
con con menores recursos
entonces en efecto ante esto es vamos a
ver qué es lo que sucede es verdad que
durante la pandemia sí que ha mostrado
que esa ortodoxia presupuestaria no
tiene por qué llevarse hasta límites
completamente irracionales y ha
reinvertido efectivamente en el sector
que su participación presupuestaria pues
ha aumentado entonces veremos veremos
qué línea tomás y la de antes de la
pandemia
las batir a elecciones básicamente de
esta crisis sanitaria no hemos hablado
de marín de penn hemos hablado de manuel
macro no hemos hablado del candidato
tercer votado más votado que sea un look
melón son los analistas dicen que el
voto entre marín de penn y el voto como
agrupación no sólo refleja una
organización de una reestructuración del
sistema político francés pero que al
mismo tiempo es un voto sobre todo de
descontento es que realmente esos votos
sólo se pueden entender como un
descontento histórico del francés o hay
también una parte ideológica finalmente
es verdad que hay un poco de todo y
también si miramos la recomposición de
los partidos en efecto vemos que en
realidad lo que sería el bloque de
macrón absorbe el centroderecha clásico
de los republicanos marín lepén pues se
afianza y además se normaliza pero
tampoco aumenta de forma espectacular al
menos en la primera vuelta en relación a
2017 y son lic menos o absorbe la la más
izquierda de los socialistas y también
recoge pues un nuevo bloque también
ecologista y socialista
pero luego es verdad que la sociedad
gala por ejemplo no es una sociedad que
tradicionalmente o al menos en los
últimos años se veía que aumentaba en
sus actitudes intolerantes
de hecho ni contra las minorías ni
contra la homosexualidad avanzaba en
términos de feminismo etcétera etcétera
esto es algo que miden las distintas
encuestas de valores
esto lo que le faltaba también era
encontrar una cierta representación
política no encontrar ciertos partidos
que llevaran esto también la cuestión
del poder adquisitivo por supuesto el
hecho de también defender a los más
débiles esto se ve efectivamente en el
éxito también de la candidatura de sonic
- son como mencionaba pero también que a
marín lepén a pesar de sus posiciones
claramente xenófobas no la votan sólo
por eso y eso también se ve mucho en su
electorado más popular en su electorado
más obrero que también tiene en la
preferencia de su voto marín depp en la
cuestión del poder adquisitivo en el
centro pues vamos a ver que dan
precisamente a partir de estos
resultados las elecciones legislativas
que ya llegan el próximo mes de junio no
estamos llegando ya al final de esta
escala en parís no me queda siendo
agradecer a aldo rubén echeverría su
presencia en nuestros estudios yo
recuerdo que usted es doctor ante y
profesor de asistencias en sociología
política además de enseñante en la
universidad de lausana muchas gracias
por habernos acompañado al dow muchas
gracias a vosotros por invitarme a
ustedes les damos una nueva cita la
próxima semana aquí en otra escala en
parís
[Música]